you have guinea pregosian hasn't been
seen in public since that Brazen armed
Mutiny around two weeks ago
his whereabouts have been a mystery
since trying to pull off that Uprising
it was thought then he cut a deal for
safe refuge in Belarus
uh
that's until the president of Belarus
Alexander lucaschenko said he's not here
he's in Saint Petersburg the equivalent
of a no comment came from the Kremlin
saying we're not following pregosian's
movements
but Russian State media is certainly on
it leaking images of an alleged raid of
the mercenary's Mansion showing a stash
of automatic weapons and ammunition and
a collection of wigs even a series of
photographs purporting to show pregosian
in a number of disguises